ja unsere nächste station ist berlin im
innenausschuss des deutschen bundestages
wird ab 16 uhr eine sitzung beginnen und
bei dieser sitzung ist
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser zu
gast und vor den türen des ausschuss ist
mein kollege erhard scherfer erhard
scherfer was wird da besprochen heute
es gibt zwei große themen heute hier im
innenausschuss der übrigens abweichender
weise im fraktionssaal der spd hier auf
der fraktionsebene im reichstagsgebäude
takt also hier hat man auch mehr platz
hier können auch mehr zu hören und hier
kann man auch mehr abstand halten also
deshalb der fraktionssaal der spd und
das wird nicht nur die bundes
innenministerin dabei sein wenn es um 16
uhr los geht auch der
verfassungsschutz-präsident halten wagen
dann haben wir eben schon gesehen auch
der wird hier möglicherweise die eine
oder andere frage noch beantworten zwei
große themenkomplexe von denen können
wir feste ausgehen dass sie hier
erörtert werden das ist zum einen weil
die flüchtlingslager also der menschen
wie im moment aus der ukraine kommen
nach deutschland da gibt es insbesondere
um die verteilung denn die allermeisten
kommen ja derzeit hier in berlin und
brandenburg an und den beiden
bundesländern kommt man so langsam an
kapazitäts und verteilungs grenzen und
sagt da müssen auch die anderen
bundesländer jetzt langsam mal ran das
ist das eine große thema mit dem man
sich hier beschäftigen wird auf der
anderen seite wird aber auch die
innenpolitische lage ort beziehungsweise
die sicherheitspolitische lage wie in
deutschland im mittelpunkt stehen da
gibt es unter uns insbesondere um die
frage inwieweit hier verstärkt in den
kommenden wochen möglicherweise auch
monaten mit cyber angriffen mit hacker
angriffen von russischer seite aus zu
rechnen ist da ist insbesondere das
bundesamt für die sicherheit in der
informationstechnologie gefragt auch das
wird also eine große rolle spielen
möglicherweise auch noch der zivilschutz
und alles was dazugehört also alles was
ich jetzt in folge dieses konflikts
dieses krieges in der ukraine abspielt
wird auch heute und was mit der
innenpolitik und mit dem
zuständigkeitsbereich der
ministerin zu tun hat wird ja auf die
tagesordnung kommen ende offen übrigens
diese sitzung heute ja dann würde ich
gerne die beiden komplexe ein bisschen
genauer anschauen beginnen wir mal mit
den flüchtenden da gibt es ja eine
andere situation was den status der
flüchtenden aus der ukraine anbetrifft
anders als der status der flüchtenden
aus syrien und nordafrika war was
bedeutet was
sie haben sich erheblich leichter in
anführungszeichen die lage ist sehr
schwierig genug aber sie müssen hier
beispielsweise keinen also keinen
asylantrag stellen wenn sie hier sicher
bleiben wollen das liegt eine
eu-richtlinie zugrunde der den
flüchtlingen die hier aufgenommen werden
in der nächsten zeit dieses die
möglichkeit sich haben also einen
aufenthaltsmöglichkeit zunächst mal für
ein jahr in der bundesrepublik das kann
dann aber verlängert werden auf maximal
drei oder vier jahre sie können sich
relativ frei bewegen es ist natürlich
abhängig davon wo man eine unterkunft
findet und welche möglichkeiten es gibt
wenn man nicht beispielsweise bei
verwandten unter kommt aber die
flüchtenden die aus der ukraine kommen
müssen übrigens nicht nur ukrainer sein
das können auch drittstaatler sein die
einen festen wohnsitz in der ukraine
hatten die können beispielsweise auch
arbeiten sie werden sie kriegen soziale
unterstützung nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
ergibt es server beispielsweise auch
forderungen hartz4 durchaus anzuwenden
und sie haben vor allem und das ist
nicht ganz unwichtig auch eine
gesundheitsversorgung feste zusagen und
kasse können sich gesundheitlich
betreuen lassen bis hin zu corona
impfungen als das ist drin in diesem
paket geht einigen nicht weit genug aber
das ist schon mal die grundbasis für
alle menschen die im moment aus der
ukraine kommen
dieser status für die flüchtenden
bedeutet auch sie haben das schon kurz
angedeutet dass die flüchten aus der
ukraine ihren aufenthaltsort frei wählen
können das führt im umkehrschluss dazu
dass bestimmte städte wie berlin oder
frankfurt an der oder wo die meisten von
ihnen ankommen im moment schon heillos
überfordert zu sein scheint was kann man
denn tun um die flüchtenden über
deutschland sinnvoll zu verteilen
da muss man natürlich erstmal gut
argumentieren können auf der anderen
seite haben natürlich die beiden orte
die sie genannt haben hat das natürlich
zunächst mal geografische gründe und
alle die hierher kommen wollen natürlich
wenn irgendwann es irgendwann geht
möglichst bald auch wieder zurück wenn
es die situation zulässt also wird man
möglicherweise auch nicht besonders weit
weg wollen oder unnötig weit weg wollen
von dem land aus dem mann kommt aber die
möglichkeiten ich habe es eben schon
gesagt sieht begrenzt in berlin ist die
situation noch relativ gut ich hatte
dieser tage der regierende
bürgermeisterin franziska giffey die von
einer ukrainischen community so hat sie
es gesagt in berlin sprach die etwa
25.000 menschen groß ist also da gibt es
viele möglichkeiten bei verwandten oder
auch bei bekannten unterzukommen aber
das ist eben begrenzt wir haben im
moment ungefähr einen einen zuwachs
täglich von ungefähr 13.000 menschen die
aus der ukraine kommen und es könnte
sich verstärken in den nächsten tagen
und möglicherweise auch noch in den
nächsten wochen deswegen wird diese
verteilung nötig es gibt unter anderem
vorschläge das etwa sonne züge oder
busse die im moment etwa aus polen
kommen oder von der aus polen kommt aus
warschau beispielsweise dass die gar
nicht erst berlin ansteuern sondern mit
den menschen dann direkt weiter fahren
in andere bundesländer das muss
allerdings noch ein bisschen koordiniert
werden obwohl es auf vielen
arbeitsebenen viele gespräche schon gibt
ihm mit den innenministerien der
bundesländer um dann zu sehen wie das
beispielsweise busse oder eben züge dann
direkt weiter fahren eben in andere
bundesländer es gibt in diesem
zusammenhang auch die forderung nach
einem sogenannten flüchtlings gipfel und
es gibt unter anderem auch die forderung
von mindestens zwei ministerpräsidenten
aus nordrhein westfalen und bayern zu
sagen dieses thema unbedingt am nächsten
donnerstag auch bei der nächsten bund
länder und die sich eigentlich nur mit
dem thema corona beschäftigen wollte
aber auch auf dieser runde dieses thema
noch mal gesondert zu erörtern die
versorgung der flüchtlinge wird viel
geld kosten ist schon klar wer das
bezahl bund länder gemeinden
nein das ist im moment noch nicht klar
aber letztendlich wird es natürlich in
großen teilen auf den bund zurückzahlen
die forderungen sind ja jetzt schon
relativ deutlich die aus den ländern
kommen die wiederum die kommunen
unterstützen müssen dass viele aus
vielen ländern schon die forderung zu
hören ist dass der bund sich der stärker
engagieren soll aber das wird in den
nächsten tagen sicherlich anlaufen und
ja das wird ein weiteres loch in den
bundeshaushalt reißen der übernächste
woche wie im bundestag diskutiert werden
sollen und dann verabschiedet werden
soll also da sind noch einige
stellen in diesem haushaltsplan für
dieses und das nächste jahr dann weiter
offen und müssen dann zusätzlich noch
gefüllt werden thema nummer 2 was sie
angesprochen haben ist die
sicherheitslage in deutschland sie haben
das schon erwähnt auch der chef des
verfassungsschutz ist heute gast im
innenausschuss das legt nahe dass man
sich durchaus sorgen macht dass der
krieg in der ukraine
negative auswirkungen auf die
sicherheitslage in deutschland haben
könnte
ja das ist das was ich eben in der tat
schon gesagt habe aber das wird alle mit
denen man spricht im vorfeld dieser
sitzung verweisen dann tatsächlich eher
auf die auf die cyber eben auf das
internet und auf möglicherweise
russische spionage aber auch russische
angriffe auf
informationstechnologie infrastruktur
der bundestag selber ist ja schon an ob
ihr ziel von hackerangriffen gewesen vor
einigen jahren das ist also alles nicht
ganz neu wir kennen auch andere versuche
die nach russland zurück verfolgbar
gewesen sind hier infrastruktur in
dieser hinsicht anzugreifen und da sind
die sorgen durchaus da dass sich das in
den kommenden wochen noch mal verstärken
könnte und ein anderer wichtiger punkt
ist dass über diese wege über soziale
medien über telegramm gruppen und andere
kommunikationswege in diesem
zusammenhang befürchtet wird dass die
gesellschaft hier weiter die
stabilisiert werden soll es gibt ja eine
relativ große russische community die
sich auch wiederum wiederfindet in anti
corona
demonstrationen da scheint es durchaus
ähnliche gruppierungen zu geben die
jetzt auch den so argumentieren dass das
was im moment in der ukraine passiert er
durch die russische bürger gesehen wird
und dass auf diese weise weiter unruhe
getragen wird in die gesellschaft
insgesamt hinein also da auch auf diesem
feld und in dieser hinsicht sind bei
durchaus einige bedenken und
befürchtungen da aber in erster linie
tatsächlich die sorge vor cyber
angriffen oder hacker angriffen durch
die von russischer seite kommen noch
noch ein stichwort
noch eine sorge stichwort tiergarten
mortis hat gezeigt dass offensichtlich
die russische führung auch nicht davor
zurückscheut auch in deutschland im
zweifelsfall einen oppositionellen
politiker zu ermorden wie groß ist denn
die gefahr dass beide seiten ukraine
oder russen diesen krieg nach
deutschland tragen und hier anschläge
und ähnliches begehen
das ist natürlich nie wirklich
auszuschließen aber das ist hier
zumindest mit denen von denen mit denen
ich gesprochen habe heute im laufe des
tages nicht explizit thematisiert worden
sondern da war die punkte die ich eben
aufgelistet habe dass es solche vorgänge
geben kann wie sie eben geschilderte
haben alfred was ist klar damit muss man
unter umständen rechnen aber das scheint
zumindest irgendwie in der öffentlichen
diskussion im moment noch nicht so das
vordringliche problem zu sein auch wenn
man die situation durchaus zur kenntnis
nimmt und da entsprechend vorsichtig ist
aber offensichtlich ist man soweit noch
nicht dass der konkrete hinweise gibt
dass ich tatsächlich dass sich das
tatsächlich so ereignen könnte